well the White House may be done with
healthcare reform for now but Republican
lawmakers are asking why there's seven
year effort to get rid of Obamacare is
still unfinished chip reads on Capitol
Hill chip good morning well good morning
Republicans are performing a political
autopsy on the health care bill but
they're so badly divided they can't even
agree on a cause of death I still
believe that there is a good chance if
if moderates and conservatives can come
together that we repeal and replace
Obamacare bring premiums down cover more
people representative mark meadows
chairman of the arch-conservative
freedom caucus which played a key role
in killing the bill blamed moderates but
ted Poe of Texas who resigned from the
freedom caucus Sunday implied in a
statement that they were to blame saying
no is easy he wrote leading his hard
leaving this caucus will allow me to be
a more effective member of Congress
instead of doing the blame game let's
get to work others in the caucus say the
fight isn't over on Face the Nation
Arkansas Republican Senator Tom cotton
said the problem was that the President
and house Republican leaders gave up too
easily I think the house moved a bit too
fast 8 18 days is simply not enough time
for such a major landmark legislation we
don't have a choice to revisit or not
revisit we have to revisit it back home
over the weekend Democrats were met with
cheers from California to Vermont but
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham was
met with the opposite in South Carolina
here's what I think about health care
Obamacare is a disaster and it is going
to collapse
and Republicans have another big worry
on the horizon next month they're going
to have to pass a major spending bill or
face the possibility of a government
shutdown and they're going to have to
find some unity to do it charlie thanks
chip